so you decided that you want to move
your application or some of your
infrastructure from an on-premises
vmware vsphere environment to google
cloud compute engine that's great
there's only one thing standing in your
way
the migration itself
there are a lot of things that you need
to consider when planning a migration
how do you choose which servers you need
how will you test your application
before moving it
how can you minimize any downtime
associated with migration
luckily google cloud offers a managed
service for migrating to compute engine
today i'm going to help you get familiar
with the latest release of migrate for
compute engine
[Music]
like the name suggests migrate for
compute engine lets you migrate your
virtual machines from your on-premises
data center onto google cloud compute
engine it's a managed service so all
this functionality is baked right into
google cloud that means you can manage
your migration from start to finish from
the cloud console or if you want you can
use a cloud api for programmatically
migrating workloads
it's got some built-in testing that will
help you validate things before you make
the move and there's no client-side
software that you need to worry about
installing on your virtual machines all
that sounds great but moving your
virtual machines from your own on-prem
racks to google cloud is a big move
let's clarify what that process looks
like with migrate for compute engine
before anything you'll need to create a
host project
this is the google cloud project that
will control the migration process
this can be the same project that will
eventually host your migrator vms but
you do have the option of using a
separate target project
you'll also need to have the migrate
connector running from your on-premises
vsphere environment
migrate connector will set your
on-premise vsphere environment as a
migration source and establish a secure
data path between it and your host
project
this is accomplished using google cloud
apis over port 443 and the traffic can
be routed via the internet vpn private
google access or dedicated interconnect
once migrate connector is set up in your
environment it will be able to perform
storage operations against your vm disks
create your on-prem vm inventory and
stop and monitor your source vms
all that is done using the vsphere apis
to get migrate connector going there are
some prerequisite steps you'll need to
complete by creating a vcenter user
generating ssh keys and configuring
network access
i'll include a link to the additional
setup associated with migrate connector
in this video's description once you've
got migrate connector and your host
project all set up the migration process
can begin going through its six phases
phase one onboarding this is when you'll
choose which vms you're going to migrate
the list of virtual machines that are
available will appear on the console
thanks to the migrate connector once you
choose your machines you move on to
phase two replication
during the replication phase the disk
data from the source vm will begin its
replication to google cloud by creating
vmware snapshots
this is done without having to take the
vm offline so there's no downtime here
after the initial replication compute
engine will then perform incremental
replications
these are replications of the disk that
occur at a regular time interval
these incremental replications can be
paused and resumed as you see fit as
replication continues you move on to
phase three
setting your target this is when you
specify your landing zone where you want
your vm to migrate to
the target details include the project
instance type and network settings
you don't have to create a compute
instance yourself because migrate for
compute engine will take care of doing
that for you
after setting your target on to phase 4
the test clone
here's where you actually clone your
source vm to a compute engine instance
for testing purposes using the latest
replication data available
during this phase you should perform all
the tests and validations that you need
for your particular application
the source vm continues to run as well
as the incremental replications
the test clone is optional but
definitely recommended to ensure a
smooth phase five the cut over phase
this is it during the cut over phase the
source vm is stopped replication is
finalized and ended and a new compute
engine instance is created on google
cloud the latest replication data
this phase will cause a short amount of
downtime so a maintenance window will
need to be implemented while you turn
down the origin machine and redirect
traffic to the cloud
if all goes well you'll be able to make
it to the sixth and final phase
finalizing your migration
at this phase all replication data and
storage resources associated with the
migration of your vms are deleted and
the vm state is set to finalized you've
migrated your vm to compute engine for
more details on those six phases check
out the documentation for vm migration
life cycle linked in the description the
goal of micro for compute engine is to
give you a frictionless migration
experience
this is largely accomplished by
performing agentless replication and by
leveraging vsphere and google cloud apis
by including the ability to deploy test
clones you're able to test workloads
before having to make the big move
best of all the end-to-end migration
journey is centralized in the cloud
console
there in the migration dashboard you'll
be able to see all the migrations in
flight view migration events manage
sources and targets and create vm groups
that you can perform bulk migration
tasks on multiple vms at once
so what do you think about migrate for
compute engine
i hope that my walkthrough of the
migration phases help you determine how
migrate for compute engine can help you
get your on-prem applications into the
cloud if you want to learn more about
migrate for compute engine check out
cloud.google.com
migrate
compute engine and check out the link in
the description for a free assessment to
estimate your cloud migration costs
thank you for watching
[Music]
you